terre ne correspond plus à nos besoins
les crises géostratégique
c'est comme les crises sanitaires c'est
pas au moment où on est dedans qu'il
faut s'en préoccuper
je pense que la france se doit plus que
jamais de se doter de moyens militaires
pour sa défense pour sa sécurité
le président trump a déclaré à plusieurs
reprises notamment à bruxelles que
c'était aux deux européens de se prendre
en charge de dépenses et pour leur
défense eh bien je pense que la
conséquence de tout ça c'est qu'il faut
que le concept de sécurité commune en
europe avance et que nous fassions tous
un effort il faut moins de diplomatie
des déclarations et un peu plus
diplomatie de l'action
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du long vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
le premier ministre libanais vient
d'annoncer la démission du gouvernement
six jours après la double explosion qui
a dévasté beyrouth hassan diab était
fragilisée après les départs en cascade
de plusieurs ministres et les
manifestations de ces derniers jours à
et les protestataires accusent le
gouvernement de négligence et de
corruption peu avant l'allocution du
premier ministre des affrontements entre
des dizaines de manifestants les forces
de l'ordre ont lieu près du parlement à
beyrouth
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous il est 19 heures heure de
paris bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
en direct sur rt france au liban le
premier ministre libanais hassan diab
vient donc d'annoncer la démission de
son cabinet il était à la tête du
gouvernement depuis près de sept mois
quatre membres de son équipe avaient
déjà démissionné depuis dimanche à la
suite de la terrible explosion du 4 août
et qui a fait au moins 160 morts et
relancé la contestation populaire
juste avant la prise de parole du
premier ministre à la tension était
encore vive dans les rues de la capitale
libanaise près du parlement
durant les manifestations de ce week end
à les protestataires ont appelé à la
vengeance dans un pays en grande
difficulté économique affaiblie par la
crise sanitaire
la pression ne retombe pas ce dimanche
dans les rues de la capitale
manifestants et forces de l'ordre se
sont affrontés jusqu'au bout de la nuit
jets de pierres gaz lacrymogènes les
rues de beyrouth sont flammes
une tension plus que palpable ces
dernières 48 heures plusieurs milliers
de manifestants ont pris d'assaut la
place des martyrs en lieu de
rassemblement traditionnel à beyrouth le
qg de l'association des banques a été
vandalisé certains protestataires ont
infiltré le ministère des affaires
étrangères avant de se faire déloger par
l'armée un policier tué et des centaines
de personnes blessées
le peuple libanais on voit un message au
gouvernement message en partie reçu ce
week-end de plusieurs députés ont décidé
de quitter le parlement notamment ceux
du parti historique chrétien kataëb
meurtri par la mort de leur secrétaire
général tués lors de la double explosion
éradiquer la corruption mot d'ordre du
peuple libanais qui entend se
reconstruire avec des futures élections
législatives anticipées décisive
d'ailleurs la communauté internationale
s'est engagée sur une aide humanitaire
de 250 millions d'euros avec un contrôle
des plus strictes et pour revenir sur
cette démission du gouvernement libanais
la politologue et historienne elle y
namur nehmé enseignante à l'université
de beyrouth nous a rejoint l'ue namur
nez mais merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors cette
démission du gouvernement libanais
est-ce qu'elle était inévitable
finalement je pense que depuis la visite
des manuels macro oui elle est devenue
inévitable parce que le président
français a parlé d'une façon très dure
au vos politiciens aux hauts dirigeants
libanais et ça a provoqué des émeutes
extrêmement violente
je pense que jamais il n'ya eu des
émeutes aussi violente et que ça a été
fortement encouragée par le discours du
président macron ensuite il ya eu ce
jour-là le dimensions dont vous avez
parlé il ya eu l'occupation de plusieurs
ministères et il y avait les démissions
de
des ministères dans les délivre dans les
ministères ont été occupés la ministre
des affaires étrangères en premier donc
ce que vous nous dites finalement c'est
que c'est le président français les mots
du président français qui ont convaincu
hassan diable de démissionner avec son
gouvernement
non pas du tout les mots du président
français ont diminué la force du
gouvernement ils ont beaucoup affaibli
le gouvernement est ce que vous savez
quand quelqu'un vient vous parier gros
dos et qu'il y à des émeutes contre vous
forcément se fortifie les les émeutiers
il y à des manifestants et des métiers
alors à quoi assiste le ton selon vous
un pays qui entrent en train de
s'enfoncer davantage encore plus dans la
crise politique où finalement au début
d'un renouveau
moi je ne crois pas vraiment une
révolution violente parce que la haine
n'amène que les jeunes peuvent certains
jeunes peuvent y croire moi je n'y crois
pas parce que je n'ai pas vu dans ma vie
une révolution violente qui n'a pas
beaucoup fait souffrir les populations
je crois aux révolutions qui viennent
d'en haut
je crois aux révolutions de style de
celle de gorbatchev
c'est le genre de révolution qui se fait
dans 10 ans dans la joie qui ne rend pas
le peuple malheureux qui s'est pas
verser de sang en plus il ya un adage
qui dit que quand une révolution est
nécessaire elle est impossible et quand
elle est possible c'est qu'elle n'est
pas nécessaire c'est que les réformes
peuvent se faire autrement
or il se trouve que ce gouvernement est
le plus réformateur de ceux qui sont
ceux qui se sont succédé ces dernières
années or c'est lui qui est en train
d'écoper tous ceux qui tout ce dont les
autres se sont rendus coupables
je vais vous donner un exemple le
ministre pendant le président de la
chaîne
ambre nabih berry est au pouvoir depuis
trente ans et il a été de tous les
gouvernements
il est devenu extrêmement riche et il
avait commencé en n'étant pas du tout et
puis soudain il
il devient quelqu'un de bien et les gens
qui n'ont pas participé aux
gouvernements auparavant deviennent des
gens très mauvais je ne comprends pas
le problème c'est que maintenant c'est
un mouvement on est en train de payer
les vols de 30 ans les privations les
actions duran printemps est ce que cette
annonce du gouvernement donc cette
démission du gouvernement selon vous
est-ce qu'elle va calmer la colère de la
rue et j'en serais assez étonné parce
que déjà il ya eu une démission d'un
gouvernement précédent qui était
beaucoup moins bon que celui là et ça
n'a pas calmé
en fait le ce qui ce qui pose problème
c'est que vous avez les responsables des
corruptions des des crimes des vols des
années précédentes ne sont pas ne
subissent pas des manifestations ils
subissent pas des émeutes ils sont pas
insulter il ya juste certains ceux qui
ont rapport avec une gouvernement avec
le pouvoir qu'ils le sont maintenant on
peut critiquer moi j'ai beaucoup de
choses à redire mais on ne peut pas
accuser le gouvernement actuel des
crimes d' étreintes un précédent comme
l'a fait le président matheron quelles
sont les réformes finalement qui ont été
faites et peut-être pas suffisamment vu
par le peuple libanais il y en a eu en
sept mois ce gouvernement a eu le temps
oui certainement il y à déjà ce que le
ministre de l'économie a fait avec le
ministre des finances et ils ont dressé
un plein de réformes que le fonds
monétaire international a accepté et
donc c'était un bon plein puisque
ce plan visait à éponger les dettes en
récupérant l'argent volé tout d'abord en
faisant un audit financier
un audit info lending audit c'est à dire
un audit avec récupération 10 ont de
l'argent et avec pénalité le problème
c'est que la classe corrompu qui est au
parlement qui est dans d'autres endroits
combat justement l'idée ils refusent
l'idée qu'il y ait un audit qu'il y ait
des réformes qu'on récupère l'argent
volé comment voulez vous que quelqu'un
qui a volé de l'argent accepte conflit
de père cet argent alors il n'est pas
logique en toute heure donc genc donc ça
fait cinq semaines que l'autre ils ont
bloqué pendant cinq semaines et pendant
tout ce temps le dollar et monter la
livre s'est effondré les gens ont
commencé à avoir faim est en tout cas ce
soir vous craignez davantage
d'instabilité politique à l'heure où le
liban on a le plus besoin
écoutez moi je suis extrêmement heureuse
là derrière moi retenait derrière moi y
ait pas de porte
ça a été soufflée par l'explosion je
n'ai jamais vu quelque chose
un état une situation aussi tragique où
il est bon non je sais je sais que
convoi sans ressortir qu'on va s'en
sortir mais en attendant c'est un moment
extrêmement difficile qu'est ce que vous
voulez qu est ce que vous pouvez dire à
quelqu'un qui vous dit je n'ai presque
plus rien qui vous dit bon mois et notre
mais notre appartement n'est pas le seul
à avoir perdu ses vitres moi j'ai failli
mourir dans l'attentât heureusement je
n'étais pas là un quart d'heure près
mais il ya des gens qui n'ont pas de
quoi réparer leurs
leurs vitres d'un univers qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire alors le cinq semaines
où le parlement a à discuter pour
empêcher le gouvernement de de faire son
odiet de conclure le plan avec le fonds
monétaire international tout ce temps là
a été perdu pour la population et vous
imaginez pendant cinq semaines de pertes
les gens qui s'ils ont besoin de manger
et qui finalement achète les denrées à
plusieurs fois le club prix vous me
demandez ce que le gouvernement a fait
part par exemple ils ont subventionné un
panier de 300 d'entre eux c'est c'est
pas idéal mais au moment où les gens
n'ont plus de quoi manger il ya eu une
fonction qui a été fait dans les
réserves
avec l'idée que on va redresser
l'économie et on pourra s'en sortir mais
avec ce qui arrive maintenant je ne sais
pas du tout et c'est pour ça que vous
avez ces démissions là parce que ce
gouvernement est venu ce sont des
kamikazes
aucun d'entre eux n'avait envie d'être
mais vous savez moi j'en connais
quelques-uns ils ont accepté parce que
il n'y avait pas moyen
c'étaient les décors ou laisse le chaos
s'installer et puis se faire insulter
pendant sept mois voir le dollar monte
avoir à affronter le paris pendant cinq
semaines alors qu'on sait que telle et
telle est l ont volé et qu'ils ne
veulent pas justement que l'audit les
découvre et fassent la vérité et
permettent aux payer de récupérer
l'argent parce qu'en récupérant l'argent
on peut payer la dette
merci à d'autres pays de dévoiler les
comptes mais là si on va on va continuer
d'en parler à merci lina mur n'est mais
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue et
nous a rejoint après cette démission du
gouvernement libanais michel to miles et
co rédacteur en chef et directeur
responsable à l'orient le jour
michel thomas merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors peut-être
votre réaction après l'annoncé de cette
démission à ce que autour de vous il ya
des premières réactions qui se font
entendre
tag réaction mais à en juger par la rue
l'aîné et les incidents se poursuivent
autour du parlement entre les
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre
alors c'est une démission qui te guette
la mer par la rue d'abord parler ce qui
mène le mouvement de soulèvement et sa
démission était réclamée par les partis
d'opposition qui qualifie ce
gouvernement du gouvernement du
hezbollah est en fait c'était un
gouvernement qui t'es peut-être un peu
trop sur la coupe du hezbollah et du
vieux parti en disque dur d'une ce qu'on
appelle ici le cpl de gibran bassil
c'est le principal reproche qu'on
faisait à ce gouvernement d'être un peu
trop sous la coupe du hezbollah donc
dans les milieux de l'opposition
que ce soit l'opposition de l'opposition
sunnite et même l'opposition chrétienne
cette démission a été réclamée depuis
longtemps et au niveau de la rue la
burgue est là maintenant la formation
d'un gouvernement
un autre enfin de pain pas d'autre des
taux d'un gouvernement qui veut dire le
système actuel c'est à dire mettre fin
finalement au système actuel
non non non et il ne s'agit pas de
mettre dauphin fin au système actuel là
il faut il faut distinguer entre deux
choses il faut distinguer entre les
pratiques du pouvoir qui sont évidemment
contestable et qui se traduisent par le
client et 10 un pack de la femis par la
corruption
ça c'est une chose les pratiques du
pouvoir et est le système politique en
place ce système politique en place
il faut que ce soit les plaines on ne
peut pas remettre en question de
remettre en cause
en quelques jours ou quelques semaines
légalité libanaise son dernier quitte ce
sont des réalités trop complexe les
l'aîné des coutumes et les clivages au
liban ont des machines qui remonte à
très loin dans l'histoire des réalités
du banney the mental à des cercles
empire ottoman
je parle du système communautaire ce
système communautaire maintenant dans la
situation actuelle on ne peut pas
remettre en cause
surtout dans le contexte actuel quand on
a des parties intégristes sunnites et
chiites et dvd et des mouvements
fondamentalistes
on ne peut pas remettre en cause ce
système communautaire
par contre les pratiques du pouvoir
c'est là qu'ils aient cessé c'est ce
volet là qu'il faut combattre
là je mange on précisément la corruption
le clientélisme l'affairisme le laisser
faire laisser aller et je pense que
c'est tessa essentiellement le message
du président macro danse qu'il a lancé
l'idée d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale
et là aussi c'est discutable parce que
la lune n'étant pas un gouvernement
d'union nationale
parce que lorsqu'on parle du
gouvernement d'union nationale ça
revient à remettre au sein du
gouvernement
toutes les contradictions entre les
différents partis et les différentes
communautés
et ça ça inhibe l'action du gouvernement
et sa part l'indicé d'action du
gouvernement c'est que la rue ce que le
mouvement de soulèvement réclame c'est
un gouvernement formé de ministres qui
ne soient pas partisan
ça ne signifie pas qu'ils sont pas
engagés évidemment les personnes nées
l'autre comme ça dans l'absolu mais le
mouvement de relèvement réclame un mini
gouvernement de ministres qui ne soient
pas partisan c'est à dire qui ne soit
pas soumis aux diktats est parti mais
qui peuvent être proches de ces partis
mais sans pour autant être soumis au
diktat des partis comme c'était le cas
du gouvernement actuel ce gouvernement
actuel la sq il a été formé il a été
présenté comme étant un gouvernement
formé de ministres non partisan et de
ministres indépendants
or il s'est avéré très rapidement
rapidement qu'une bonne partie de ces
mines de ses ministres étaient soumis au
diktat des différentes formations
politiques qui ont soutenu la formation
du gouvernement
essentiellement le hezbollah le
mouvement chiite et le mouvement du
président de la chambre nabih berry et s
ministre clément un moment donné ils ont
affiché une année sans jouer qu'un truc
un bisou à afficher leur allégeance à
ces formations politiques
donc ce le défi actuellement est de
former un gouvernement
deux ministres non partisan qui soit
suffisamment michel touma on a
effectivement un problème de liaison
alors on va essayer éventuellement de
vous retrouver on va poursuivre nôtre
notre édition a donc je vous le rappelle
le gouvernement libanais a donc
démissionné une démission qui intervient
alors que depuis des années est la
communauté internationale réclame aux
dirigeants du pays des réformes et une
lutte contre la corruption et le drame
de mardi dernier semble avoir
sérieusement mise à mal sa confiance
envers les autorités libanaises est
réuni hier lors d'une visio conférence
co-organisée par la france et l'onu à
les donateurs internationaux ont annoncé
qu'ils allaient directement distribuée à
la population les plus de 252 millions
d'euros des deux victimes de l'explosion
il existe une enquête transparente sur
les causes de la catastrophe
elad masculine 250 millions d'euros
c'est le montant de l'aide
internationale qui sera apportée en
urgence à la capitale libanaise
alors que les dégâts matériels se
chiffre à plus de 15 milliards de
dollars montant que le liban lourdement
endettés ne peut financer seule
le président du pays s'est adressé
directement aux donateurs durant la
conférence de soutien moral à ce qui a
été dit d'oublier redonner de l'éclat
je demande beaucoup à attendre habana
café
les besoins sont très importants et nous
devons accélérer mourir
rendre surtout avant l'arrivée de
l'hiver à car la souffrance ghadirian
sans abri bah ça qu à la lumière de tout
cas la cia stressante
parmi les engagements annoncés l'union
européenne souhaite contribuer pour 60
millions d'euros au programme les états
du golfe ont également ouvert leur
portefeuille comme le qatar enfin
l'allemand nous allons annoncer dans les
prochains jours notre participation à la
reconstruction de beyrouth à travers les
programmes qui seront retenues enfui
avec l'afnor à contretemps nous nous
sommes dépêchés de répondre à l'appel de
nos frères du liban et à leur fournir
une aide d'urgence aux médias évalué à
50 millions de dollars
puma puma toro ram sous le menu ont de
leur côté américain sans fournir de
chiffres donald trump a annoncé que son
pays était désireux de fournir une aide
au peuple libanais ou sucrés de
l'humanitaire nous nous devons de le
faire on doit le faire c'est on peut se
demander comment un pays peut survivre à
une telle tragédie c'est un tel niveau
que des gens là bas me disent qu'ils
n'ont jamais rien vu de tel auparavant
ils n'ont jamais rien vu de semblable à
cette explosion
nous allons donc les aider et de façon
importante le royaume-uni a lui annoncé
une aide de près de 22 millions d'euros
l'espagne la norvège le danemark ont
aussi confirmé leur contribution
financière
l'aide sera coordonnée par les nations
unies et fournit directement à la
population libanaise
ces 250 millions seront répartis sur
quatre axes prioritaires la santé
l'alimentation la réhabilitation des
écoles ainsi que la reconstruction des
logements ravagé soit un vaste chantier
en perspective
et on continue de parler de cette
démission du gouvernement libanais avec
michel tout ma co rédacteur en chef et
directeur responsable à l'orient le jour
quelques soucis de connexion mais là on
vous voit bien on vous entend bien
michel tout m'a alors on vient
d'entendre un la communauté
internationale va donc apporter une aide
dit
acquittement au peuple libanais une
posture finalement pour afficher sa
méfiance envers les dirigeants du pays
vous pensez que ça a eu un impact sur la
décision de cette démission du
gouvernement
cette posture de la communauté
internationale je ne pense pas que
c'était sale le facteur déterminant
d'abord il ya eu aujourd'hui et depuis
hier et dans la journée d'aujourd'hui il
ya eu une vive tension entre le premier
ministre le président de la chambre pour
des concerts et des considérations de
prérogatives
c'est à dire le premier ministre a
annoncé samedi qu'il allait proposer des
élections anticipées
un an de prison la chambre a considéré
que c'était une atteinte aux
prérogatives de la chambre parce que
c'est à la chambre a décidé s'il faut
écourté le mandat de la queue parlement
ou non
donc ça ça a créé une tension entre le
premier ministre le président de la
chambre et ça a accéléré disons ça a été
un catalyseur qui a accéléré la
démission du gouvernement
mais pour en revenir à date
internationale effectivement cette aide
est destinée à être octroyée directement
à des ong ou à des associations qui soit
crédible
ah non ça ça pose effectivement ce que
je disais tout à l'heure le problème de
la confiance confiance envers la classe
10 ans dirigeante ce ce qui implique la
nécessité de la formation d'un
gouvernement non partisan de former deux
ministres crédible et intègre et essai
c'est à ce niveau que le président macro
je pense est intervenu lorsqu'il est
venu à beyrouth
il a fait passer le message il a émis
l'idée d'un changement de gouvernement
justement pour modifier des pratiques du
pouvoir
donc ce qui est en cause actuellement au
liban ce n'est pas de remettre en cause
la diversité parce que le pays le liban
est un pays d'une mosaïque de 18
communautés et un est un pays fort mais
qui est basée sur la diversité
donc il s'agit pas de remettre en cause
la diversité en tant que tel était son
expression au niveau du pouvoir
il s'agit de modifier radicalement les
pratiques du pouvoir celle des maîtres
en tant qu aucun délit
séguin michel thomas michel tout m'a
justement pour mettre fin au
clientélisme à la corruption ce qui ad
des figures dans le pays est ce qu'il ya
des groupes politiques qui pourraient
incarner ce changement selon vous
seulement il ya seulement il ya des
formations politiques
il y avait des parties qui peuvent un
cabinet ce ce ce changement de mentalité
dans les pratiques du pouvoir
il ya de nombreuses personnalités de la
société civile qui peuvent incarner ce
changement aussi bien dans les pratiques
que du pouvoir et et même du
gouvernement actuel concocté plusieurs
ministres qui pouvaient qui représentait
un peu ce changement de 2,2 mentalité ce
moment heureusement ce gouvernement n'a
vraiment sortant était il faut le
reconnaître était sur la coupe des
intérêts sur la coupe du trône là donc
il ya au sein de la société civile ou
bien au sein de certaines formations
politiques en place de nombreuses
personnalités beaucoup de cadres l'un
qui peuvent incarner ce changement de
mentalité et ce changement dans les
pratiques du pouvoir
et si il faut une évolution il faut
qu'il y ait une évolution au niveau du
système politique
mais cette évolution doit faire l'objet
d'un dialogue entre toutes les
composantes de la société libanaise mais
un dialogue qui doit se faire dans une
atmosphère sereine calme dans un cadre
de paix civile et non pas dans une
situation de situations bien vieille
permanente où il ya un parti qui chacun
coûtant fait des déclarations
incendiaires et qui déclare la guerre à
des pays amis au liban et qui portent
des coups de jarnac aux relations entre
le liban et les pays arabes ou bien même
la communauté internationale
international de dialogue national la
refonte du système politique doit faire
l'objet d'un dialogue en profondeur ce
des bases rationnelles des dans une
atmosphère sereine la réalité du niveau
réalité très complexe qui n'est pas
nouvelle et qu'il n'est pas le fruit de
la gagne c'est une réalité qui remonte à
avant même l'emportement donc je remonte
à au 19e siècle
au début du 19e siècle on ne peut pas
changer cette réalité comme ça en
quelques jours ou en publiant des
communiqués ou en faisant une
déclaration
ça nécessite vraiment un débat en
profondeur
michel thomas vous parlez là quelques
instants du du hezbollah est ce que
cette crise politique que vit le liban
est ce que le hezbollah peut en
bénéficier ce qu'il peut peser davantage
sur la politique du pays selon vous ils
pèsent déjà suffisamment sur la
politique du pays
s'il peut pc de peser davantage
je pense que ce serait encore un peu
difficile parce qu'il est il est
suffisamment présent à cause justement
de dans son axe rennes lille et un mail
alex gauna à un choix stratégique a fait
le problème quelques secondes là au
départ est le suivant ce que dans la
doctrine politique du hezbollah telle
qu'elle a été définie au milieu des
années 80 en 1985 il est écrit noir sur
blanc que pour les questions d'ordre
stratégique et plus précisément pour les
questions de guerre et de paix le
hezbollah est soumis à la volonté de ce
qu'ils appellent eux de ben ali et de sa
crise c'est-à-dire concrètement c'est le
guide suprême de la révolution iranienne
qui était à l'époque romane et lorsque
le hezbollah a été formé dans les années
80 et qui axe actuellement l'ayatollah
ali khamenei donc pour les questions
d'ordre stratégique
essentiellement tout ce qui se rapporte
à l'allemand du hezbollah la décision de
guerre et de paix le hezbollah semble
mais un familier ce qui est une
situation totalement absurde
mais imaginez qu'en france par exemple
avec un parti x sera soumis à la volonté
de poutine par exemple l'art donnez moi
oui pardonnez moi mais je paye et on
arrive au terme de cette édition
je vous remercie d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes co
rédacteur en chef et directeur et
responsable à l'orient-le jour merci
pour votre décryptage une édition donc
consacré essentiellement à la démission
du gouvernement annoncée par le premier
ministre libanais il était à la tête du
gouvernement depuis près de sept mois
quatre membres de son équipe avaient
déjà démissionné depuis dimanche à la
suite de la terrible explosion du 4 août
qui a fait au moins 160 morts et relancé
la contestation populaire
juste avant la prise de parole du
premier ministre à la tension était
encore vive dans les rues de la capitale
libanaise après du parlement durant les
manifestations ce week end les
protestataires ont appelé à la vengeance
dans un pays en grande difficulté
économique affaiblie par la crise
sanitaire
écoutez un extrait de l'allocution de
hassan diab au lait ne vient aujourd'hui
j'annonce la démission de ce
gouvernement
que dieu protège le liban que dieu
protège le liban que dieu protège le
liban vive le liban et c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain point sur l'actualité dans un
peu plus de trente minutes rester avec
nous sur rt france à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
alors où je